We've been talking about the question,
what arguments might be offered for
the existence of a soul and a family of
arguments that were considering
initially our arguments that get known as
inference or inferences
to the best explanation.
The thought is that there's something
about us that needs explaining.
We can't explain it in terms
of impure Lee physical terms.
And so we need to appeal to, we need
to posit the existence of a soul. Now,
I'll come back to that sort of
argument in just a minute, but,
uh,
let me,
let me bracket that for a moment and say
something about Plato a starting next
week, we're going to be looking
at Plato's dialogue, the Fito.
And so although I'll be saying
a great deal about the fetal,
once we turned to it,
I want to just take a minute or two and
say a couple of introductory remarks.
I don't know how many of you
have not read any Plato before,
but for those of you who haven't,
I actually think you're in for a treat.
Plato's not only one of the
greatest philosophers in history,
he wrote his philosophy, uh,
in the form of dialogues.
Uh,
that is to say plays a in which various
characters sit around or stand around
and argue about philosophical positions.
Yeah.
The particular dialogue that we're going
to be reading the Fito is set at the
death scene of Socrates.
Socrates's I'm sure you know,
Socrates was put on trial,
condemned to death for corrupting
the youth of Athens. Uh,
perhaps among other things for
arguing philosophy with them. Uh, and,
uh,
the,
he's given hemlock a poison
and he drinks it and he dies.
Now this is a historical
event. Amman, Socrates had a,
a circle of friends and disciples
that he would argue philosophy with.
One of his disciples was Plato.
Plato then, uh, you know,
grew up and wrote philosophical works.
Plato does not typically
appear in his own dialogues,
or if he does, he's only, there
is a minor character. In fact,
if I recall correctly,
Plato's mentioned as not being
there on the day that Socrates dies.
MMM.
So how do we know if you've got this play,
whose position is Plato's position?
And the answer to the short
answer is soccer cheese.
The character Socrates in the
play represents playdough,
the author of the plays
philosophical views. Now in fact,
if this were a class
in ancient philosophy,
we'd have to complicate that picture
because it's fairly clear that by late in
Plato's career,
Plato is,
has philosophical views that are very
much unlike the views of his teacher
Socrates.
And yet Plato continues to
not appear in the dialogue.
Socrates continues to be sort of the hero.
And so scholars debate,
you know which of the s the view is put
forward by Socrates in which ones have
the dialogues represent views that
belonged to the actual historical figure
soccer teas.
And which of the views put forward by
the character of Socrates in which of the
dialogues represent views
that are actually not held
by the historical Socrates,
but were instead held
by the historical Plato.
And we're merely put in the mouth
of the character of Socrates,
no scholars distinguished between the
early platonic dialogues that so called
Socratic dialogues where the thought
is those are the views of Socrates,
the actual historical figure.
And then there's the late dialogues
where even though Socrates appears,
most scholars believe those are probably
not the views that the historical
Socrates actually believed.
You have middle dialogues where you have
to worry about whose views are who's,
but, but we're not going to worry. We,
this is not a class in an ancient
philosophy, and so for our purposes,
we don't have to ask ourselves when soccer
teams in the dialogue says something,
is this a view that the dead man Socrates
actually would have held or is this
simply a view that the dead man Plato put
in the mouth of the character Socrates?
For our purposes,
it won't really matter.
I'll take every view that soccer t's
puts forward as a view of Plato's though,
I'll talk, I'll, I'll typically sort
of run back and forth sort of in a,
in a careless fashion.
I'll say Plato holds or Socrates argues
because for our purposes it's all the
same. But there's one other complication
that you've got to be warned about,
which is this because these are dialogs
and they take the form of philosophical
arguments,
people put forward views and then over
the course of the discussion changed
their minds about things and and they,
and they take them back and,
and maybe something similar is going on
when soccer gs said something because
after all it says isn't Plato saying,
you know,
here's what I believe explicitly.
He's just writing a dramatic
play about philosophy.
And so sometimes we'll find
ourselves thinking, you know,
there's an argument here that Socrates
is putting forward but maybe it's not a
very good argument and it will at least
be worth pausing periodically to ask
ourselves.
Maybe Plato realized it
wasn't a very good argument.
We can often better understand the
dialogues by seeing Socrates as putting
forward certain positions that he does
not think are all together adequate and
he modifies them,
revises them,
or introduces new positions to deal with
some of the difficulties that he was
setting himself up to be open to earlier.
They say,
don't worry about any
of those details now,
but it's a point to keep in
mind as you read the dialogue.
So that's all I really wanted to say.
By way of introduction,
you should start reading
the Thedo for next week.
We'll be talking about the fito starting
sometime next week and we'll continue
the discussion of the Fito,
uh,
for at least a bit of maybe
all of the week after that.
In the case of Plato,
I'm going to make an exception.
Normally I will mention our readings,
but I won't spend a lot of time
actually discussing them in detail.
That's why you have to think of the
readings as complimenting the lectures or
think of the lectures as complementing
the readings. I'm not just giving,
you know, the cliff notes as it were,
uh, of, uh, of, of the readings.
Nonetheless,
in the case of of the Pheto,
I am going to spend more
time actually saying,
here's what I think the
first main argument is.
Let's try to reconstruct it in terms
of its premises, in his conclusions.
Here are some objections I raised.
Here's then the next
argument that Plato offers.
Let's try to get that up
and premises even there.
I won't be spending time reading out loud,
long passages from the Fito,
but in some sense I'll be giving a closer
commentary of the Fito then I'll do
for the other readings.
So,
so what you shouldn't do is
start reading it from next week.
The, that topic of the
Fito. As I say, it's,
it's set on Socrates last day.
You know,
at the end of the dialogue he
drinks to hemlock and, and he dies.
And perhaps unsurprisingly,
what he does with his friends up until
that moment is he argues about the
immortality of the soul. Quite
strikingly, Socrates is not upset.
He's not worried about the
fact that he's going to die.
He actually welcomes this in a certain
way, uh, because he believes his,
his soul is immortal.
Uh,
and so in addition to
philosophical arguments for
and against the existence and
the mortality of the soul, uh,
we end the dialogue with a,
with a quite moving a death scene.
One of the sort of, you know,
great death scenes, if we could call
it that, of, of Western civilization.
As I said,
that's all for next week.
So let's return now to the question,
how might we argue for the
existence of the soul? Initially,
last time we considered a set of, or a
subset of arguments that basically said,
look, there's gotta be more to
us than just material objects.
People can't just be machines because
machines can't reason machines can't
think. And I said, that doesn't
seem to be a compelling argument.
After all chess playing computers,
it seems can reason they have beliefs
about what I'm likely to do next.
They have desires about the goals
that they're trying to achieve.
They reasoned about how best to defeat me.
And it's,
and it's worth pointing out that it's
a point that I didn't make last time.
It's worth pointing out
that what the computers,
at least the best chess playing
computers don't do. Indeed.
No computer actually does this.
You might,
you might think that what a computer
with a chess playing computer does is
justice. It calculates every
possible branch, you know,
every possible game from here on out.
And then it sort of works backwards.
Or these are the ones where or when.
And so it only makes the moves where it
can sort of look ahead, 20 moves, right?
And see which branches
have the computer winning.
That is not the way chess playing programs
work for the simple reason that the
number of possible chess games is so
huge that computers can't calculate it.
They'd be busy for thousands of years.
I mean, we can do that sort of thing.
When you play Tic Tac toe with your, you
know, seven year old nephew or niece,
you just look ahead and work backwards.
Well, if I do that, he'll do that.
He'll do that and then he wins.
So I won't do that. Right.
But we can't do that with chess.
There's just too many games.
So how do chess playing
programs in particularly the
best chess playing programs?
How do they work? Well, they
play chess the same way you do.
They have various ideas about which pieces
are more powerful and so they're more
important to protect.
They've got various ideas about which
strategies tend to be successful,
what sorts of dangers
come along with them.
If you're a serious chess player,
you might study some of the Great Games
of chess history and indeed when they
program these things, uh, the
programmers will feed in, you know,
gain after game after game of the Great
Chess Games in history and then arm.
With all of that you sort of do your
best and when you'll lose a game you kind
of make a mental note to yourself
that really screwed me up.
Let me try something different next time.
And you avoid those sorts of moves.
That's how chess playing
programs work as well.
Jumping ahead and let me,
let me just make a remark about this
because there's going to be relevant for
something I'll get to in a couple
of minutes. What this means,
what this w that the implication is that
if you're playing a great chess playing
program,
it's not as though the way to tell what
it's going to do is to study its program
and think it through.
The the people who design these programs,
presumably fairly decent
chess players themselves,
the people who designed these programs,
when they're playing the programs,
they're not thinking to themselves,
let's see,
I programmed this computer so that when
I move a queen forward that to this
space,
it should come out with the bishop.
That's hopeless because the program is
constantly revising its strategies in
light of what's worked and
what hasn't worked in the past.
When the programmers play these
programs or indeed when anybody,
a good chess player plays these programs,
the best way to try to beat
them as simply ask yourself,
what's the best move to make right now?
The odds are that computer's gone
and make the best possible move.
Treat the computer as though it
were just a great chess player
and indeed the best programs
are great chess players.
And then there was a period of time in
which although they were decent chess
playing programs, couldn't beat
the best chess playing humans.
That ended some years ago when the best
programs began to beat a grand masters.
Uh,
and now it's in fact the case of the best
programs can beat pretty much anybody.
Uh, in the, the current
world champion of chess.
I think Vladimir Kramnik was defeated
in December by a chess playing program.
So no crop chrom Nick's simply treating
this as an awesome opponent and that's
the best way to deal with
these things. All right, so
bracket some of those
thoughts for a moment.
We'll come back to them a little bit
later when we start talking about the
question. Could machines be creative? No.
Tipping my hand seems pretty clear that
that seems like the right thing to say
about these chess playing programs.
So we had the question,
couldn't machines,
could machines reason?
And although we don't have machines that
can reason about a lot of subjects yet
it seems pretty clear.
It seems like the natural thing to suggest
machines can reason or at least some
areas.
And so it doesn't seem
plausible to suggest that we
people must not be physical,
merely physical. Because after all we can
reason to no machine can reason. Nope.
Machines could reason.
But this prompts a different move on
the part of the defender of souls.
Perhaps the,
the argument shouldn't be we have to
believe in souls because no mere physical
object could reason.
Perhaps the argument should be we have
to believe in souls because no mirror,
physical object,
no machine could feel
no. We have emotions
we love, we're afraid,
we're worried.
Okay,
we'll get elated,
we get depressed.
So perhaps the arguments
should go, yeah, yeah.
Thinking that's the sort of thing
I'm machine can do. You know,
we call them thinking machines,
but feeling that's the sort
of thing no machine could do.
No purely physical objects could
feel anything, could have emotions.
And so since we clearly do feel things,
there must be more to us
than a physical object.
Now
I think it is plausible to suggest
that unlike the case of, you know,
chess playing computers, we don't
yet have machines that feel things.
So, but the question isn't
do we, the question is,
could there be a machine
that could feel something,
could have an emotion of some sort.
So let's go a little science fictiony
and think about some of the robots that
have been shown in science fiction movies,
some of the computer programs that have
been shown in science fiction movies,
science fiction novels,
or what have you.
When I was a kid, there was a
television show called lost in space.
I'm afraid I've forgotten
the name of, uh, the,
the robot that was on that show. Uh, but
as it was Katie, I was a TV show. And so,
you know, sure enough,
every single episode,
some new dramatic danger would take
place and the robot would start,
you know, whizzing and binging
and shout out, oh, danger,
commander Robin. So danger will Robinson.
That was a danger. Will Robinson.
It seemed as though the robot was worried.
More recent example number of you have
probably read some of Douglas Adams is
books, the hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy. Uh, and, uh, the sequels to that.
There's a robot, uh, in, in
those books. Marvin, who's, uh,
depressed, uh, I think is the simple
word about it. He sort of, you know,
he's very smart. He thought about the
universe, thinks life is pointless. Uh,
and uh, he asks depressed,
he talks to another robot,
depresses the other robot, the other
robot commit suicide. Um, all right.
Seems natural to ascribe
depression to Marvin the robot.
That's how he behaves.
Okay.
Or my favorite example,
uh,
the movie 2001, a space odyssey.
Now I've got to tell you,
for those of you who've not seen this
movie, I'm about to spoil it. All right?
So you cover your ears
in 2001,
a space odyssey.
We get some kind of indication that
there's life on another planet.
It's all various mysterious and we send
off a us a spaceship to investigate,
you know, the markings, the, the, the
radio signals from the other place.
This is a very important mission.
And so there is a a computer program
named howl that helps run the ship and
takes a lot of the burdens off of the
part of the human astronauts who are on
the ship.
How's got the goal in terms of reasoning,
desires and so forth and so on.
How's got the goal of making
sure the mission is successful,
but how thinks to himself fairly
plausibly humans really screw things up.
This is a very important mission.
Let's kill the humans to make
sure they don't screw things up.
Yeah.
One of the astronauts discovering the
plot attempts to stop how and proceeds to
do and the only thing he can do
to defend himself against how,
which is shut down the program basically
killing if we can talk that way.
Killing how meanwhile,
as all this is going on,
howl and Dave, the human, uh,
astronaut are talking to each other.
How realizes what's going on?
How tries to stop Dave
understandably enough.
And how says as day begins
to shut down house circuits,
I'm afraid. I'm afraid.
Dave, what's he afraid of?
He's afraid of dying.
Seems perfectly natural.
Right?
To a scribe.
Fear to how,
how is behaving in exactly the way you
would expect him to behave or it to
behave if it felt fear,
it's got reason to be afraid.
It's behaving appropriately.
It's telling us that it's afraid.
It seems natural to say,
how's afraid now you could continue
to sort of fill in examples like this.
As I say,
of course they're all science fiction,
but the fact that we can grasp and you
know it says that we go running away
saying, oh no, this was outrageous.
Right. This then it makes no sense.
I think the computer could have said,
I'm afraid.
It makes no sense to think that it could
try to kill the people who are trying
to shut it down and so forth.
Okay.
Oh, that seems to me to be
prejudice. As I said last time,
the natural inclination here is
to say these computer programs,
these robots are feeling emotion.
Okay,
but there's no particular reason to
think there's anything going on there.
Then the circuits,
they're just physical objects.
Programs on machines.
Yeah.
If that's right,
if that's the right thing to say,
than what we have to say is we don't need
to appeal to souls in order to explain
emotions and feelings.
Physical objects could
have mere physical objects,
could have emotions and feelings,
so we have no reason to posit
the existence of a soul.
Now I think the best
response on the part of the,
the dual list to this reply is to
distinguish two aspects of feelings to of
emotions.
There's the behavioral
aspect of feeling fear.
Let's say
the,
the behavioral aspect is when you're
aware in the environment of something that
poses a danger to you know,
that will harm you or destroy you or in
the case of a computer program turn you
off. Then you take various
kinds of behaviors in,
in a,
in the opposition to that to try to
disarm the danger to try to neutralize it.
This is just a matter of
beliefs, goals, responses,
planning,
the sort of thing that we already saw.
The chess playing computer can do
that behavioral side of emotion.
Okay.
Seems pretty plausible to
think robots could do that.
Physical objects could do that.
And here's what,
here's the crucial
point of this objection.
There's another side or another
aspect to emotions and feelings.
It's the,
it's the sensation of
what it's feeling like.
That's why we call them feelings
after all, what it's feeling like.
I'm the inside as it were.
While all this behavioral
stuff's going on,
when I'm afraid I have this certain sort
of clammy feeling or my heart's going
pounding Lee, you know your, your blood
is racing, right? When you're afraid,
you got this sinking feeling in
the stomach when you're depressed.
There are these, well, we could
call them experiences though.
The word experience is also somewhat
ambiguous. So we'll use it for the moment.
There's an experience that
goes along with each emotion.
There's what it feels like
to you when you're afraid,
what it feels like to you when you're
worried or depressed or joyful or in low.
Okay?
And the thought, and I think this
is a pretty powerful thought,
is that even if the robots
are behaving behaviourally,
they've got the behavior
side of the emotions down.
They don't have the feeling side at all.
Now,
once you start thinking these thoughts,
there's no need to restrict
yourself to emotions. The, the,
the missing stuff.
The missing thing is there in all
sorts of familiar humdrum ways as well.
So No, right now I'm looking at, you
know, the chairs in the auditorium.
There are some kind of shade
of blue. Think about, you know,
look at someplace in the room
where the curtains with their red.
Think about what it's like to see red,
the sensation of seeing red.
Now again,
we've got to distinguish between the,
what I'll continue to call the
behavioral side of seeing red and the
experiential side of seeing red.
It's easy enough for us to build a
machine that can tell red from blue, no,
just checks and sees what kind of light
frequencies are bouncing off the object.
And so we can build a machine that
could sort red balls from blue balls.
My son has a little robot
that can do that. Still.
When you think to yourself,
what's the,
what's going on inside the machine?
What does it feel like to be the machine?
While it's looking at, well, I've got
this little light sensors, you know,
pointed at the,
the red ball.
Does it have the sensation of seeing red?
What I suppose you want to say?
Certainly what I want to say is no, no,
it doesn't have that sensation
at all. The it, it's, it's, it's,
it's, it's sorting things
based on the light frequencies,
but it doesn't have the experience
of seeing red. You know,
this is what we're trying to get
at here is it can be very elusive,
but I imagine most of
you are familiar with it.
It's the sort of thing you wonder about
when you ask yourself if somebody was
born blind,
could he possibly know what
it's like to see color?
He might be a scientist and know all
sorts of things about how light works.
No.
The such and such frequencies in which
objects you hand them an apple and I'll
say, oh, must be very red. Right?
Maybe he points his little,
his little light detector at, at and
an, and it reads out. It says, you know,
this is such and such a frequency.
Says, oh, this is a very red apple.
Much better than that tomato or whatever.
But for all that we've got the notion,
not only is he not seen red,
he can't even imagine what it's like
to see red never having had these
experiences
and once you start to see this,
we realized of course our life
is filled with this aspect.
Things have colors, things have
sounds, things have smells.
There's the qualitative
aspect of experience.
Yeah,
and the point that I started with earlier
about sort of the internal aspect of
emotions is it's not just out there,
but inside as well.
We have certain kinds of
sensations inside our body.
Yeah.
The characteristics,
sensation of fear or joy or depression.
All right,
so they're suggesting
there might be this what,
what no physical object can get cause
no physical object can get it all is the
qualitative aspect of experience.
That's the aspect that we're after.
When we ask ourselves,
what's it like to see red?
What's it like to smell coffee or tea?
Taste pineapple.
Now it's pretty full.
Philosophers sometimes qualities thing
call these things [inaudible] because of
the, the notion of the
qualitative aspects of things.
Our experiences have
qualitative properties
and the suggestion then
might be no physical object.
No mere machine could possibly
have qualitative experience.
But we've got it.
So we're no mere physical object.
We're no mirror machine.
All right now the, that's the
objection. That's pretty good objection.
And then the question is what can
the physical essay in response, no,
the best possible response would be for
the physical list to say here's how to
build a machine that can be conscious
in this sense that is have a qualitative
experience. Here's how
to do it. Here's how to,
just like we can explain in materialistic
physicalist terms how to get desires
and beliefs in the behavioral stuff down.
Here's how to get the,
the feeling qualitative
aspect of things down too.
It would be best if the physicalist
could give us that kind of story.
And I think the truth of the matter
has to be, I think, I think the, the,
the answer right now is we don't
know how to give that story
consciousness.
If what we mean by consciousnesses,
this qualitative aspect of,
of our mental life consciousness
remains a pretty big mystery.
We don't know how to explain
it in physicalist terms
and it's because of that,
that I think we shouldn't be dismissive
of the dualist when the dualist says
we've got to believe in
souls in order to explain it.
We shouldn't be dismissive,
but that's not to say that I
think we should be convinced
because it's one thing to say we don't
yet know how to explain consciousness in
physical terms.
It's another thing to say we won't ever
be able to explain consciousness in
physical terms.
If we had
the ladder,
okay,
excuse me. If we had the, the bold claim,
okay.
That no physical object
could see red taste,
honey.
Okay.
Then we'd have to conclude since we can
do all that we're not a physical object
or not merely a physical object.
Okay.
But I don't think we're yet
in a position to say that.
I think the simple fact of the
matter is we don't know enough about
consciousness yet to know whether or not
it can be explained in physical terms.
When I think about this situation,
I, an analogy always occurs to me.
Imagine that we are somewhere in let's
say the 14th century trying to understand
life,
the life of plants a,
it is a living thing.
And we ask ourselves,
could it possibly be that life could
be explained in material terms?
It's going to seem very mysterious to us.
How could it be when we think of the kinds
of examples of material machines that
we've got available to
us in the 14th century?
And I try to imagine what would somebody
in the 14th century think to himself or
herself when he entertains the possibility
that a plant might just be a machine.
And, and then I have this little image of,
uh, some, some plant made out of gears,
right? And the gears begin turning
and the bud opens dot, dot, dot, dot,
and and the, and the person's just going
to say, my God, that wouldn't be alive.
So it's pretty obvious that
no machine could be alive.
No material object could be alive.
In order to explain life,
we have to appeal to something
more than just Adams.
He didn't have Adam's but you
know more than just matter.
Life requires something in material
above and beyond matter to explain it.
That would have been an understandable
position to come to in the 14th century,
but it would have been wrong.
We didn't have a clue back then how
to explain life in material terms,
but that didn't mean it couldn't be done.
Okay.
I am inclined to think the same thing's
true right now for us and consciousness.
I know that are,
there are theories out there,
but my best take is we're pretty
much like in the 14th century,
we don't really have a clue yet or not
much of a clue as to how you could even
so much as begin to it.
It's not that merely that we
don't have the details worked out.
We don't even have the picture in broad
strokes as far as consciousness is
concerned.
How it can be done in physical terms
but not seen how it's possible is
not the same thing as seen that it's
impossible.
If the dualist comes and says,
can't you just see that
it's not remotely possible?
It's not conceivably possible for a
purely physical object to have experiences
to have quality.
What I want to say is no,
I don't see that it's impossible.
I admit I don't see how to do it,
but I don't see that it's impossible,
so I don't feel forced to
posit the existence of a soul.
Of course, the the, the fan of
the soul could come back and say,
but that's not fair.
The question isn't,
is this explanation impossible?
The question is just,
who's got the better explanation?
You guys can offer any kind of
explanation at all yet I can offer an
explanation.
How is consciousness possible?
We have souls.
Souls are really very different from
physical objects and so they can be
conscious.
Yeah.
But at this point I think it's crucial
to remember the point that it's not just
the question, you know,
who's got an explanation,
but who's got the better explanation?
And before we say that the soul
views got the better explanation,
we have to ask ourselves just how
much of an explanation is it to say,
Oh,
I can explain consciousness consciousness
is housed not in the body but in the
soul. Okay. How exactly is it
that a soul can be conscious?
We ask and then the sole
theory says, well, um,
er, uh, it just can,
that's not really much of an explanation.
I don't feel I've got any sort of account
going here as to how consciousness
works.
Even if I become a dualist.
If the dualist where to start off on us,
you know,
some elaborate theory of consciousness.
Well,
other z sorts of soul structures and
those sorts of souls structures and these
create these sensations and those create
those sensations. And here's a theory.
Well then I'll begin to take
it seriously as an explanation.
But if all the soul theorist is just
saying is Nana, you guys can't explain it.
And I can,
because I say this is an explanation,
then I find myself wanting to
say that's not really any better.
That's no improvement at all.
There was a question or comment.
Yeah.
Capabilities to explain the consciousness.
Is it not also possible
technological capabilities to detect soul.
So the question was,
first was the accusation
before the question that I'm
holding on sort of double
standard. I'm defending bar. I'm
defending the physical list by saying,
you know, don't blame us. We
don't know how to explain it yet.
Why aren't I allowing the sole
theory to say don't blame us.
We don't know how to explain it yet.
Good question.
And my answer is in some sense I
think this one's a tie. All right.
I think the sole theorists
doesn't have an explanation.
The physical theorist doesn't have an
explanation as far as I can see right now,
nobody's got a good explanation
about how consciousness works.
It's a bit of a mystery right now.
So I don't mean,
I hope I haven't been doing this.
It's not so much a double
standard is needed. It's a tie.
But notice if it's a tie that doesn't
give us what we were looking for.
What we're looking for after all was some
reason to believe in souls and if the
best the sole theorists can say is,
I can't explain it and neither can you,
that's not a reason to believe this side.
We already believe there are bodies.
Okay,
we all ready know bodies can
do some pretty amazing things.
The question we're asking is,
is there a good reason to add
to our list of things there are.
Is there a good reason to add the soul,
something immaterial,
and if the best that the
soul theorist has is,
maybe we need this to explain something
that I don't see how you guys can
explain. Maybe this would help
do, I can't quite see how either.
That's not a very compelling argument.
So what I'm,
what I'm inclined to think with regard
to this particular strand of this
particular version of the
argument is the jury's still out.
Maybe at the end of the day we'll give
it our best. We'll decide, you know,
you can't explain consciousness
in physical terms.
We'll begin to work out some sort
of alternative, immaterial theory.
Okay.
Maybe at the end of the day we will
decide we need to believe in souls,
but right now I don't think the
evidence supports that conclusion.
Okay.
Still there's other possibilities.
Yeah.
Consider creativity.
Here's another version of an argument
that goes from inference to the best
explanation. Creativity. It
says people can be creative.
Yeah. We, we write new pieces
of music. We write poems,
we prove things in mathematics that
I've never been proven before. We,
we find new ways to prove these
theorems or what have you,
and we can be creative.
No mere machine can be creative,
so we must be something
more than a mere machine.
Okay.
Well, again, the question's going to be,
could it be the case that there could
be a physical object that's creative
and I'm inclined to think yes.
In fact,
I already suggested as much when I
talked about the chess playing computers,
that chess playing computer programs.
Okay.
Think of moves.
Think of strategies.
No one's thought of before
in the most straightforward,
natural meaning of the term.
We'd have to say no. When the,
I think the program that the beat the
world champion was called Deep Fritz.
So in deep Fritz beat Kramnik,
it was being creative and it made a move
the chronic didn't think of and perhaps
it nobody had perhaps no chess
game before it had this move.
Computers can do other sorts
of things of this sort. Uh,
there are mathematical
theorem proving programs.
No,
no.
Some of these things can prove things
that you know mathematically way over my
head. But let's take something
simple like the Pythagorean Theorem,
which we all learned in high school and
we learned how to prove the Pythagorean
theorem in Euclidean geometry,
starting with the various axioms of
you'll clean look Euclidean geometry,
you know, bump up, up,
up, up, up, up a bomb.
This proves Pythagorean theorem and it
turns out there's a variety of proofs of
the Pythagorean theorem.
And in fact,
computer program has come up with
a proof that as far as was known,
nobody in the world had
ever come up with before.
Well,
other than prejudice,
what would stop us from saying
the program was being creative,
not just any sort of mathematical things
like chess or, or math. Uh, there are,
as you know,
programs that can write music and I
don't just mean throw out some random
assortment of notes,
programs that,
uh,
you know,
can produce music I have that
we recognize as music that had,
have melodic structure and develop themes,
resolve
music that nobody's heard before.
Why not say the machine is creative?
What other than prejudice
would stop us from saying that?
So if,
if the argument's going to be,
we need to posit the existence of a soul
in order to explain creativity. Again,
that just seems wrong.
Well,
there's a question comment
this,
just like a scientific way to make a
machine produce something that pass hasn't
been used before.
But the question was when I
talk about creativity here,
am I trying to build in some appeal to
the feeling that we may have when we're
being creative? And the answer
is no. All I had in mind.
As you notice just in talking
about the creativity issue,
I just have in mind
producing something new,
producing something that hasn't been
around before and most particularly
producing something that your programmers
didn't go already have in mind.
Remember,
it's not as though the people who designed
the chess playing programs can beat
it.
The chess playing program makes moves.
These guys haven't thought of.
Yeah.
All right. The creativity
argument may not work, but,
but there's something that sort of
immediately comes on. It's heels.
Even if we could build a program,
even if we have built
programs that can be creative,
they can do things that
nobody's thought of before.
Oh, the program is doing
is following its program.
Right?
It's just a series of lines of code and
and and the robot or the computer or
what have you is just,
you know,
automatically mechanically following
the code commands of the program.
We might say even if we are smart
enough to build programs that can buy
mechanistically following the program,
do things we've never thought of.
Still all the computer can do.
All the robot can do is automatically
necessarily mechanically follow the
program.
It doesn't have free will,
but we have freewill.
So here's a new argument for
the existence of the soul.
Okay?
People have freewill.
Yeah,
no,
merely mechanical objects.
No robot,
no computer could have free will.
Okay.
But since we've got freewill,
we must be something more
than a merely physical object.
There must be something extra,
something immaterial about us.
The soul.
Yeah.
So maybe that's why we need to believe
in souls in order to explain freewill.
Now
th th th the subject,
freewill is a very,
very common subject.
Consciousness is a very complicated,
no one could have an entire
semester devoted to thinking
about the philosophical
problem of consciousness.
And indeed as it happens in our
department this very semester,
there is such a class devoted all
semester to the topic of consciousness.
One could similarly have,
uh,
a course devoted to the
problem of freewill.
Okay,
I'm going to spend all of,
you know, two minutes on it.
So it's by no means do I mean to suggest,
oh, here's everything and you know,
about the subject.
I simply wanted to point out enough
about the problem to help you see why I
don't think free will's a slam dunk
for the soul.
So, so what's the
argument? Well, the, the,
the thought seems to
be something like this
one
we have freewill.
Okay.
To,
let me say something about this.
What is it about the thought that the
computer is just following a program while
there thought,
I suppose is and philosophers jargon
that the computer is a deterministic
system.
It follows the laws of physics and
the laws of physics are deterministic.
You know that if you're in this state
you will necessarily given the laws of
physics and the way the computer is
programmed and built and so forth, these,
these, you know, these wires will turn
on, turn off, these circuits will turn on,
turn off, boom. Suddenly you'll
be in that state. You know,
there are certain laws such a given
that the computers in this state,
it must necessarily move in that state
when you've got a view about cause and
effect that works this way
for everything that happens.
There's some earlier thing that caused
it to happen such that given that earlier
because the event had to follow.
That's a deterministic picture
and the thought of course is that the
robot or the computer is a deterministic
system and you can't have freewill
if you're a deterministic system.
So
well number one we have free will
to
nothing subject
to determinism
has free will.
Okay.
Put One and two together.
It follows if nothing's subject to
determinism has freewill but we have free
will. It follows that we're
not subject to determinism.
Okay.
It's supposedly then add three.
All right.
Surely physical systems,
yeah.
Are subject to determinism.
Well one and two gave us that we
are not subject to determinism.
Three says all purely physical
systems are subject to determinism.
What would follow them from one,
two and three that we are
not a purely physical system.
So conclusion for we are not
a purely
physical system.
All right.
That's the argument from freewill.
Yeah.
Now the argument is valid.
That's philosophers jargon.
That is to say given the three premises,
the conclusion really does follow.
Okay.
The interesting question is,
are the three premises true?
And they've got to all be true.
It's got to be that every
single one of them is. So
yeah.
I'll just spend a minute more
on this starting next time,
but the point to think
about for next time is just,
is it really true that all
three of the premises are true,
or my one or more of them be false. All
right. That's where we'll start next time.